yeah man my i feel emotional right now
man
i feel emotional my eyes are tearing up
bro
man it's just bro is
it's real man because
it's bro you go through these things and
you're right but it's like these things
happen
and and um you know that you
you're not giving more than you can but
dude like
i look back and i'm just like damn bro
that [ __ ] was tough bro that [ __ ] was
tough y'all can bleep that out man
well that was tough bro and
it does bro it does make you into who
you are so like people who are going
through something
you know mentally mentally you will
put yourself down after the abuse ends
but like that doesn't
that doesn't mean that you have to that
doesn't mean that you have to and it's
like
mentally you think you're nothing that
you're not worthy of anything that you
are the same thing that this other
person was putting you down to be
but it's like i had to go through all
these things and like for myself i
realized like
dude i'm so much more i'm so much more
than
what this person was making me out to be
and whoever is going through something
like you as well
so much more than whatever this person
was making you want to be and it's like
my guy
i'm over here about to go into
professional
martial arts for professional mma like
do you guys see
the amount of uh physical uh
suffering these people go through not
just in the fights but in their training
like my god i thought to myself and like
the
that you know that like that negative
voice that we all have
where it's like you you're thinking of
doing something and let's say romney's
over here thinking
about applying to this school you know
let's say fire bro you're over here
thinking about doing
um residency at
this certain place over here right and
like you're thinking to yourself okay
i'm gonna go over here but then this
negative voice comes in yeah it's like
bro you can't do that and you don't
deserve to do that
and like we know what that is we know
what that is it's shaped on it
but it's like you have this little voice
in your head the same 9 but like
what makes you think that you deserve
that
what makes you think that you'll be able
to handle the amount of pressure
that's going to come with that the
amount of sacrifice that you have to do
you know what
you're better off doing this over here
you're more suited for this over here
bro i have that voice come in my head
all the time
and then it's like subhanallah bro when
i take a step back
and i really see it for what it is like
bro
a lot has been getting me ready for this
my entire life
like yeah i may not have had the
background
of um fighting all the time i may have
not started martial arts at a very young
age
but you know what bro i went through
abuse
physical mental emotional spiritual all
this kind of abuse here
for eight years
like if i'm not ready then i don't know
i don't know whoever is going to be
ready so i was like bro
i'm just saying man like it's
it's all part of the plan and sometimes
we just can't see that because we're too
close up
[Music]
you know you can do this without school
you already know that you can bring in
money
now the question is can you bring home
some paychecks and show that to mommy
and daddy
can you prove it that you can do it
because at the end of the day
they still have this traditional eastern
philosophy that you need to go to school
we came here we sacrificed our life for
you to go to college
so you can get this degree and make this
money whereas bro
i keep preaching this you don't need
school if you don't need school
if you're not trying to be a doctor
you're not trying to be a lawyer you're
not trying to be
some type of engineer i'm talking about
an actual practical engineer
right not like a programming uh you know
software engineer that can
that's you could do it from your laptop
bro now
these types of things go go to school
but you don't need one to be a software
engineer
can you be a software engineer through
school of course
can you be one without school of course
so why take the route that you might
have to
indulge in ribba in interest in student
loans
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
welcome back to the teeth we end
we're here with i'm here we're here with
romney and we're here with imam
even nafis so today we're going to be
talking about working past
um what i would say is traumatic
experiences
or um setbacks in life
you know for example um abuse from
parents
you know this doesn't have to be
physical abuse this could be emotional
abuse this could be neglect right
things that society doesn't really talk
about because we don't have a great
record of you know dealing with mental
health
properly um i i read a quote recently or
a comment that said um
america and you know americans spent so
much time preparing for a war that they
weren't ready for a pandemic right
they're not ready for things like mental
health
they're ready for you know uh
hand-to-hand combat but not you know not
the mental game
so we're gonna be talking about that and
i think best to talk about that
would be brother on him masha allah um
so take the mic all right with
permission from uh
the mom right right
permission thank you bro thank you
jessica all right so uh
what do you guys want me to talk about
you guys want me to go in
on like how it all happened do you want
me to
yeah i mean share i mean first and
foremost share whatever you're
comfortable sharing whatever you think
would be helpful you know we can drive
lessons from
um but start wherever you want to start
you can start like when it first began
when you first noticed it was an issue
how you felt in the beginning i'm
talking about the mental
are you talking about about everything
bro everything and go go in assuming
that
people don't know the level that we know
assume there's someone coming that
that's been like yo what is that guy in
a tank top with tats gonna talk about
going like that and to be frank i really
don't know that much
so i'm i'm in the same viewers
standpoint
damn y'all putting me on the spot i'm
literally counting down to lana i was
like
guys i think we should start this
podcast again i swear i was about to say
it bro i swear i was about to say it was
in my head i was like we should start
this over
nah it's been it's been a good two
months since we've done that so for the
sake of continuity let's just keep going
yeah yeah great great for the sake of
continuity
all right so
uh i think i was like nine or ten years
old
uh my mom started going out with this
one dude
and the dude seemed pretty cool at first
you know fast forward and then um
he's living at the house his daughter's
living at the house with me and my
sister
and uh things kind of just start going
downhill from there where it's like this
guy
he seemed cool at first but he turned
out to be the devil in disguise because
it first started with this dude
just being really firm and aggressive
with me in terms of like
uh vocally like telling me either to do
something or to not do something like
i mean as a kid you know you don't like
that right i don't think anyone likes
that even adults but it's like
you kind of get it where it's like ah
well he is kind of like a father figure
at this moment in time because he's at
the house he's
with my mother you know he's he's the
man of the house
for like a better word so it's like um i
i basically you know as a kid i would
submit i would listen
to this authority huh because like what
else am i gonna do get my ass beat or
get grounded and have all my video games
taken away from me
and i'll be able to go outside and play
with my friends come on now like i'm
sure any kid would have done the same
thing
so that continued and then it got to
points
where um
[Music]
a guy would actually tell me to steal
something
we were at a store and he would tell me
here
take this and put it in your pocket and
i was like
like i'm not gonna do this like
i'm gonna get caught and i remember one
time i didn't do it
and he gave me this look like
all right i just wait just wait was just
see what's going to happen
and when we got back home this man
hey i was walking to my room and then he
came over
and i'm like going into details i
probably shouldn't go into details
but um i mean i'm already doing it so
i'm like walking into my room
and uh i can hear him behind me
like he's walking with me he's behind me
and there was no one else in the house
was just being him
and i remember as soon as i got in my
room i walked
into a corner to like grab something
from a shelf
and then he just closed the door and i
like looked back and i swear like this
this like panic just came over me
because i didn't know what was going to
happen
just me and him alone in the house and
this dude just closed the door like
there's no one else in the house
and this guy literally just closed the
door behind him
and then i asked him i was like like uh
like
are you good like is everything all
right
and this man just looked at me he didn't
say anything
he didn't say anything he just looked at
me and the amount of anger and rage i
could see in this man's face
was just out of this world and as he got
close to me he just
punched me as hard as he could in my
stomach
and i don't know if you guys have ever
gotten punched
really hard in your stomach especially
in that top portion
whereas like the moment you get hit it
takes all your air
and like he hit me right there to where
i couldn't breathe and i was literally
down on the ground trying to get my
breath
suffocating for lack of better words and
um
she was just putting me down man like as
i'm there trying to get
air into my lungs this man literally
called me a pansy
call me a [ __ ] saying that i ca i'm not
worthy of anything that like i'm not
worth anything either
i can't even do a simple thing like that
like how am i gonna do anything in my
life
and um that's that's very little like it
gets worse and worse and worse over the
years
but um
to to fast forward here i the the whole
point of this is that
this got me to
be very suicidal at times where i would
just want to end everything because it's
like dude i was being
oppressed i was being oppressed big time
i was being abused
physically mentally emotionally
spiritually everything
like i'm talking about i didn't i did
not want to live anymore i didn't want
to tell anyone
because i was scared i was scared of
telling someone because the moment i did
tell someone
this man actually acted like there was
nothing wrong
like i'm talking about this man put up
the biggest
front in history towards like the people
who i told
what he was doing to me which was my
best friend at the time my best friend's
dad
he convinced him that he wasn't doing
anything that i was just making it up
and y'all like i i paid for that
and i'm not going to say what happened
after that but i'm going to tell you all
that i paid for that
and um being abused like that being
oppressed like that
i don't think that i feel suicidal but i
had evil thoughts man like i had things
going on in my head where it's like you
know what tonight
while he's sleeping i'm going into his
room i'm gonna slit his throat
and i'm just gonna end everything i
don't care what happens after that i'm
just gonna end everything
and there's it's just it's evil things
that would go in my head because of what
was going on
and what's even more crazy is that after
um after he was no longer in my life do
still lives
i do still live he's still out there but
after this dude was no longer in my life
i no longer had anyone abusing me i no
longer had anyone oppressing me
but it continued on for like a good
what four six four to six years
where i was abusing and oppressing
myself
and like it it took this whole journey
of like
um getting deeper into
meditation because i wasn't i wasn't
into religion at the time i wasn't into
islam i wasn't a muslim so for me it was
like all right well
i know there's something wrong you know
that's when i found out that i also had
the addiction with pornography but it's
like
if you look at addictions addictions
occur because it's just
your way of trying to cope with
something
like yes you have certain people who
have a certain
balance of uh and i must say just for uh
uh the imam ibn nafis here uh the
certain neurochemistry makeup
where it's like some people might
actually be more inclined to be more
addicted
some people might not but i'm just
saying like an addiction in and of
itself is you trying to cope
with something that's usually something
from your childhood it's something that
happened to you as a kid
that you haven't dealt with and i had
the addiction to pornography and that's
when you know
things kind of began uh
clicking and my eyes started opening up
and i started seeing oh okay
um yeah i have these issues i have all
these things that happened when i was a
kid
and i've been running away from you i've
been trying to shut it out because
when you're a kid and you go through
something traumatic you actually try to
shut it out you try to do
something to disregard what's going on
and it's like fi yeah i remember the
story you told me in iceland
where you were uh i'm talking about your
childhood i'm not gonna go into i'm not
gonna say details because your story
you wanna talk about you can but like
what you said
and how you dealt with it is exactly
what i'm referring to
in the sense that you basically tried to
shut it out
you try to close yourself off to it and
try to um
not think about it you try to basically
act like that didn't exist like that
wasn't happening in your life
and that's what happened with me when i
was being
when i was going through this whole
abuse and everything i was trying to
run away from it and that just continued
on later in life so
um i guess with the whole point of this
video
people who do or people who have gone
through something like this
you gotta sit down with yourself it's
gonna be the hardest thing you ever do
is sitting down with yourself not having
any distractions not having any friends
or family
not doing anything just sitting down
with yourself
with what's going on in your head
and literally just starting to break it
down
piece by piece because i'm gonna tell
you something
you got a lot of layers if you look at
an onion
an onion has a whole bunch of layers
listen the amount of trauma
that we have even people who didn't go
through that much trauma the amount of
trauma we have
is like this big ass onion and you have
to keep peeling all the layers back
little by little it doesn't happen
overnight it's gonna take a long
time
man thank you for sharing that real
quick though i just wanted to ask you a
question
let me see if you could relate do you
ever realize
when i realized you ever forget
sometimes how much
and what you've been through and it's
almost like you got to remind yourself
[Music]
i mean think about it um maybe the minor
things yeah but like
the real things that i've been through
it's it's never gone bro it's like a
stain
it's always there though
[Music]
do you think in some way shape or form
it has helped you you know develop
yourself
to who you are all right so
uh i spoke about this in the uh
the freshly grounded podcast where he
asked me he's like what's one thing
about your childhood
that um you love or that you
[Music]
are happy that you went through and i
told him i was like yo this is gonna
sound sadistic
but um i'm really grateful for the fact
that i was abused as a kid
because yeah it was messed up i went
through a lot of turmoil
a lot of suffering but like who i am
today
would not be if it weren't for going
through that
you know what i mean yeah so back then
obviously you saw it as a very bad thing
right oh yeah so nowadays
you don't look at it like it's a bad
thing it's still a bad thing
but it was like i see it more as like
it was just a trial i'm not going to say
a necessary evil because it's like bro i
don't wish that upon like my worst enemy
to be abused but it's like it was a
trial
and again it's made me
who i am today i feel like bro if i
wouldn't have gone through that
i probably would be a pretty soft
individual
yeah yeah
i want you to tell me about how that had
an impact and
if it did and you picking mma as a
career
oh yeah so i think it had a gigantic
impact and this is
this is why i feel like it's all the
color of allah
it's all bro it's all written and it's
like the way
the way that we are meant to go about
this life the way that we were meant to
[Music]
not just express ourselves not just
think not just
all these things but like live actually
live this life
and you know work as an instrument for
the creator
i feel like that's all written
beforehand
and like bro our life experiences and
the things we go through is
all part of that and it leads us to that
because my guy i came from puerto rico
and i'm just giving a little backstory
here
all right but i came to puerto rico i
was four years old
and i remember being in a
pre-kindergarten
not knowing any english not knowing much
spanish
i knew spanish but it's like
i don't know i was a late learner you
know i learned
more physically than i did mentally we
already spoke about this
i'm a very physical individual and
when i was in pre-kinder i remember all
these kids would laugh
and i would think they were laughing at
me so brad was fighting every little kid
on the playground
for real for real bro i remember i
remember i was on hanging on you know
the the bars that go into like where you
can like do dips
yeah they had these like two bars i was
like hanging upside down
i remember this like little boy was
coming in and this is gonna sound gay
but it's not gay obviously because
you're a little kid you don't know any
better um you only know
literally like survival instincts and
being in the present that's it as a kid
so i'm like i'm hanging off this thing
upside down this little kid
comes and he's saying something to me
but i don't understand what he's saying
so it's like i'm already getting upset
because he's like saying something
he was probably asking if i wanted to
play or something like that
but then he started laughing because i
just kept looking at him i didn't
respond
and when he when he started laughing i
got so mad i bit this dude's nuts bro
i bit buddy's nuts man he started crying
so bad i remember
the teacher uh hit up my mom she's like
yo like we can't have
him here he's um he's
he bit this dude's nuts
and my mom was like listen he's not
savage he's just
he doesn't understand so like they had
to have the lunch lady
like basically translate everything for
me but aside from that aside from that
i went through that period where like
from a very early age i was already
fighting
right and and i didn't get into much
fights after that
so it's like all my fighting was like
early and then now it's like i do
mma but um in between that time frame
i remember i was going into elementary
school and like bro i was always
i was always a goof bro i was always
like laughing and making other people
laugh
um so i never had issues with people you
know i never had issues with people
people always love being around me
people always love like joking around
with me and stuff like that so i never
had
people wanting to fight me for no reason
or for some beef or something like that
i'm never happy
never had beef and then once this dude
came into my life i think i was in like
a fourth or fifth grade and when he came
into my life
and like i said he started to oppress me
and put me down
this man would uh sometimes he would put
me into submissions
like an actual like a rear naked choke
or like a leg lock or an ankle lock or
an
arm bar or something like that and like
he
you know i'd be like almost yelling in
pain and he wouldn't stop
and there was time where like he would
hold me and i would literally go
unconscious
i would literally black out he would
hold me so
long like i would i would be tapping him
to let go
and he would keep going until i was
fully knocked out
and it was crazy because like you
usually don't experience
anything when you're knocked out it's
almost like you close your eyes and then
you open them back up but you're in a
different position
and he would do that and
i remember there was a part of me that
was just
so upset and like i had been just so
manhandled
and just so put down by this one
individual that
i a part of me never wanted to go
through that again
and because i never wanted to go to that
again um i started putting up this uh
this front as if i was this uh this
really tough dude
and then i would always um i would
always get in people's faces
and keep in mind i didn't get into any
fights
after elementary nothing crazy
nothing crazy but it was all because of
me
it's because me trying to act hard me
trying to act tough
and like basically make people believe
like oh
this guy's like this guy's you know he's
tough dude like you don't want to mess
with
and i remember
when i actually got into a situation
where like things were about to get real
heated
like after that situation nothing
happened right nothing happened but
it wasn't me being the aggressor this
time someone else was aggressing me
but i was standing my ground and then i
remember after that situation
i sat back and i thought i'm like
damn like i really don't know how to
fight
like i don't know how to defend myself
and then fast forward like a month or so
later
my boy was like yo i'm doing martial
arts right now
in my home gym you should come check it
out
and i'm not gonna get into the whole
story of that but it's like
it's all being geared into that it's
like i went into martial arts with the
idea of you know what i'm gonna protect
myself i'm gonna do this
so i can beat anyone's ass whoever comes
in me whoever tries me but then it's
like the moment i did it i
i experienced nothing but freedom and i
was like wow
i really don't need to put up this front
i don't
need to act like this hard individual i
can just be
myself and you know what if it comes
down to it
and i have to throw hands or throw legs
or just use my body
you know be violent like i'll do it
because i know how to do
it you know i'm not going to be
scared i'm not going to be hesitant
because i'm training
when i'm training i am preparing it's
like kobe bryant said in one of his
videos made rest in peace man
in one of his videos he was like that he
he's he's cold-hearted
he's cold-faced cold stone when he's
playing his games
they ask him like oh bro like do you not
care he's like no it's not that i don't
care it's just
i've played this thousands and thousands
and thousands of times where it's like
this isn't new for me
so i'm not anxious i'm not nervous i'm
not over here
emotional this is just another training
thing for me this a game is just another
it's another game it's another training
session so for me if i were to get into
another fight
i'm not nervous i'm not hesitant it's
just another training session
maybe a little bit more um is on the
table
but it's just another training session
you feel me so i feel like that's
that's the whole thing of the uh mma i'm
going off here
yo so that guy your your mom would uh go
out with for those couple years
was his father present in his life
oh his father abused him i knew it bro
his father abused him so he was
basically passing down
that trauma it's like he got hurt so now
he's hurting someone else it's like that
same goes hurt people hurt people
yeah but the abuse becomes the abuser
exactly bro exactly do you know much
about that story or no
uh i don't
so he just didn't deal with it and then
he just used you as the outlet
pretty much and was the only one before
you
i don't know i don't know man um
probably
probably man cause um last last time i
heard about this guy
he uh supposedly he's like
because he has daughters and you know
the one daughter that he had that was
staying in the house with us
she's still like best friends with my
sister but she doesn't have any contact
with him
she completely cut off contact with him
because bro he treated her bad too
you know like maybe he wasn't abusing
them to the extent that he was abusing
me
but he still treated them bad and she
said that
he also has two other daughters they're
like smaller
and she said she was in contact with
them
and that the last thing that she heard
was that uh
he doesn't have anyone to release his
anger on
so he's literally just beating his dogs
which is pretty messed up man
it's pretty messed up though but
that's that's how it is bro that's
when when people are oppressing people
are abusing
is because they are hurting themselves
they are going through something
themselves that
they are not confronting so they are
projecting and
putting it out onto other people um
yo y'all remember two nights ago when we
were playing call of duty
and i asked you guys if you watch joker
yeah
that's exactly what you're saying bro
yeah man that movie was hard to watch i
know man rami said it wasn't but that
demo was hard to watch yeah romney's
like damn bro i could relate to that on
an emotional level i was like what
[ __ ] yeah romney is joking bro
[Music]
let me tell you one thing before both
y'all jump in
the thing that you said was like the
abuse
the abusey becomes the abuser
brother that's facts man like i've
i've never abused anyone thankfully but
like i know that
i would have gotten there because when i
was a kid and i was going through this
abuse with him i remember i was in the
backyard with one of my friends at the
time
we were playing some game run and think
about it i'm a kid so i'm in like fifth
to sixth grade
we're playing on the trampoline we're
jumping and i think we're playing some
game and i got really mad and i just
punched him really hard bro i'm talking
about i punched him
really hard almost in his throat
and then he started crying bro and like
as i saw him crying i just like
i literally saw myself in the position
that he was in when he would abuse me
and like bro like that
that made me sick bro that almost made
me throw up
as a little kid bro so it's true
it's true that the the abusee becomes
the abuser
in these uh situations
[Music]
i feel like i'm at a loss of words now
don't be a [ __ ] bro it sounds very
abusive see that man just messing with
you
it's hard bro it is hard yeah
yeah um i agree with everything you're
saying um
especially the uh you know abuse
becoming the abuser in the end um but i
think that i feel like that's
that's only if you know they don't deal
with it properly um
as humans i feel like we you know we
mimic a lot of the behavior uh we see
from others especially
when we're growing up um it's a lot of
it's like you know environmental so
um and i'll add to that it's a traumatic
experience right
um i feel like a lot of the time the the
traumatic or the the
experiences that stand out the most um
tend to have the greatest impact on us
that's why you know a lot of fetishes
are just a result of childhood trauma
and it comes out in like your sexual
life which is a big you know aspect for
a lot of people
um for or for everybody so it's it's
it's really sad that you know
uh this is the case that when you go
through something traumatic in that in
that sense
and you don't end up dealing with it you
end up becoming that traumatic
experience
and it really it shapes who you are and
i feel like that's why um
good mannerism is a good character is
such a you know a fundamental part
of islam said i came to perfect good
character
and there was you know a huge emphasis
on you know how he treated his family
and the best of you are those who are
best to your family because they're the
most
vulnerable around you especially if
you're the man of the house the father
figure
um uh subhanallah so it's
it's sad that you know these are the
issues we're still struggling with today
you know yeah man you guys have been
through quite some stuff but i will say
that
a lot again this is not some like new
age
new religion type thing that you see on
tumblr growing up
like god gives his tough toughest
battles to his strongest soldiers or
something like that what i'm saying is
allah subhana wa tala never gives soul
more than it can bear
and at the end of the day this is
something that i constantly you know go
through in my head
and i constantly make an intention to
have it run through my head every day
throughout various different things it's
like at the end of the day bro
no matter where you are in life
everything is perfectly the way it's
supposed to be
it might not seem like that right now it
might seem like
like everything's just falling apart but
the way things are right now
is the way they were already predestined
to be and the only way
that things can go for everything to go
the perfect way
in the future but it's not going to seem
like that in the moment
100 yeah luckily you want to say
something
yeah man i feel emotional right now man
i feel emotional my eyes are tearing up
bro
man it's just bro it's
it's real man cause
it's bro you go through these things and
you're right but it's like these things
happen
and and um you know that you
you're not giving more than you can but
dude like
i look back and i'm just like damn bro
that [ __ ] was tough bro that [ __ ] was
tough y'all can bleep that out man
well that was tough bro and
it does bro it does make you into who
you are so like people who are going
through something
you know mentally mentally you will
put yourself down after the abuse ends
but like that doesn't that doesn't mean
that you have to
that doesn't mean that you have to and
it's like mentally you think you're
nothing that you're not worthy of
anything that you
are the same thing that this other
person was putting you down to be
but it's like i had to go through all
these things and like for myself i
realized like
dude i'm so much more i'm so much more
than
what this person was making me out to be
and whoever is going through something
like you as well
are so much more than whatever this
person was making you want to be and
it's like my guy
i'm over here about to go into
professional
martial arts for professional mma like
do you guys see
the amount of uh physical uh
suffering these people go through not
just in the fights but in their training
like my god i thought to myself and like
the
that you know that like that negative
voice that we all have
where it's like you you're thinking of
doing something and let's say romney's
over here thinking
about applying to this school you know
let's say fire bro you're over here
thinking about doing
um residency at
this certain place over here right and
like you're thinking to yourself okay
i'm gonna go over here but then this
negative voice comes in yeah it's like
bro you can't do that you don't deserve
to do that
and like we know what that is we know
what that is it's shaytan
but it's like you have this little voice
in your head the same name bro like
what makes you think that you deserve
that
what makes you think that you'll be able
to handle the amount of pressure
that's going to come with that the
amount of sacrifice that you have to do
you know what
you're better off doing this over here
you're more suited for this over here
bro i have that voice come in my head
all the time
and then it's like subhanallah bro when
i take a step back
and i really see it for what it is like
bro
a lot has been getting me ready for this
my entire life
like yeah i may not have had the
background of um
fighting all the time i may have not
started martial arts at a very young age
but you know what bro i went through
abuse
physical mental emotional spiritual all
this kind of abuse here
for eight years
like if i'm not ready then i don't know
i don't know whoever is going to be
ready so it's like bro
i'm just saying man like it's
it's all part of the plan
and sometimes we just can't see that
because we're too close up
any kid going through even like a sliver
of what you went through
in the moment they're like bro why is it
me why me why me why couldn't it be
why couldn't i just have a normal stable
you know family like everyone else
why does it have to be me but you look
at it now and it's like
bro i can't think i can't say that i
know anyone that's been through what
you've been through
that's trying to go into the mma that's
trying to go into the ufc
like this it's not going to happen bro
and it's like who else just like you
said better suited than you
so before i i ask you what your
in your opinion and romney 2 where you
guys look at
as the best things to heal the wounds
and the best things to rip the bandaids
off
i'll give i'll give my two cents on what
i think it is
and again this might not be
yeah nothing we say is like uh to like
you know we're not
psychologists or like counselors
anything this is just anecdotal
experience right for me i would say
before i tell you what it is i feel like
a lot of people and this is especially
the way society is structured
it makes you want to feel bad
about your strengths and it makes you
i mean my bad it makes you want to feel
bad about your weaknesses
instead of feeling good about your
strengths so from a very young age
we'll put we're institutionalized we go
to school
and it's like you see people that are
different learners just like angel said
he was a kinesthetic learner he wasn't a
mental
or verbal learner and then you have a
kid like this
and you're basically standardizing him
or
using a measuring stick that society
uses
and he's different and a lot of kids are
different and you got these kids feeling
bad because they're not
they're not measuring up to the standard
that the school has set up
so for example if some kid is really
good at gym
right like they're a really physical guy
but they're not good at english
bro why are you making this kid do
english now i get it there's a basic
level of competence that i feel like
every
every kid needs to have right like it's
it's
it's against a lot for you not to go to
elementary school
and middle school and i believe
secondary school too like they will find
you
but it's like i feel like after that bro
why are you
why are you you know dancing to their
tomb i don't get this
because at the end of the day like
imagine it like this
you got a kid here who is forever gonna
doubt himself and his strengths just
like you said
because he's only having his weaknesses
shown across his face by society by
school
school's telling him yo you're not
really good at math you're not really
good at science you're not really good
at english
therefore your average grade is this and
you're not gonna be you're not gonna
amount to anything in life
whereas this kid's probably getting like
really good grades and let's say
geography
or something what if that's like his
purpose you know what i mean
so he's never gonna know that because
society keeps making you feel bad for
your weaknesses now
what i feel like is far more resourceful
is focus on your strengths first
you know i'm not going to tell you you
know neglect your weaknesses you know
assume they don't exist but what i will
say is don't worry about them right now
double down on your strengths make that
like times 10
and worry about your weakness but by
that point you already know what you're
good at
you feel me and everyone's good at
something there's no there's not gonna
be anyone that's that's like oh i don't
have a purpose so
you might feel like that now but there's
definitely something that everyone's
good at
now my biggest thing
dealing with these these issues that i
was talking about
it puts you in a very particular
scenario or situation when
the people that you love and the people
that you
hold really close to you or even if you
don't love them
they're in a position where they're
supposed to be looking out for you kind
of like you're
the guy that your mom was with right
even if you didn't love him
he was supposed to be in a position for
you to love him
right because he was he was supposed to
be the leader of the house that father
figure
but he was never there bro so you could
never look up to him as right
what i would say is with people like
this if these are the types of people
that are abusing you neglecting you
making you feel
worthless right and it's very difficult
because it's like bro
these are your loved ones these are your
kin you can't really abandon them
what i will say with these people is
again instead of cutting them off or
you know thinking revenge you're like
trying to like use your your
your traumatic energy and put that on
another individual what i will say
is just distance yourself from them now
i'm not gonna say
you know be you know have mal intentions
and like
distance yourself and when they hit you
up don't don't hit them back up i'm not
saying that bro
but what i am saying is if they're only
gonna come at you sideways
and that's literally the only language
that they speak you don't need that in
your life
i don't care if it's literally your
brother your sister
if they're coming at you sideways i'm
not saying cut them off but it's
them being the transgressor not you
bro come on like what are you gonna keep
going with that and you're just gonna
let that drain you day by day
and they're not gonna realize what
they're doing now if it's someone that
you you know it doesn't matter like
let's say it's a boss but let's say it's
it's like
you know some other environment bro get
out of there what are you doing at a job
that
you're not respected at you know you
know you know they don't like you they
don't want you but
you've somehow associated keeping food
on the table with them
and now this guy is like the source of
like your survival
and provisioning well that makes no
sense because allah is the only
provider provision or sustainer right
but with important people i would say if
you could make things work you know
always be civil but
if if they're just gonna keep coming at
you sideways man it's like
you gotta you gotta realize who's first
because if you let that get to you
and bring you down bro everyone is gonna
crumble because you gotta be the person
that everyone looks up to you gotta be
the person that's in charge
so if you crumble it's not gonna work so
how are you going to take care of other
people first and put them above your own
needs
and let that affect you and then it's
going to affect everyone else
yeah that's facts 100 i feel like this
is something a lot of people struggle
with
um a lot of time i get messages from
people asking you know
my my mom's acting like this my father's
acting like that what should i do
right i can't exactly cut them off what
do i do um
and a lot of the times it's unfortunate
because when you're in that position you
can't really do anything
you can't just leave the house at this
you know um
this age you're not ready for that um
they're your parents they don't feel
like they have to listen to you so
you're trying to talk to them isn't
going to do much
uh you know there's not a lot of people
you can reach out to and this is the
issue because a lot of the time
you know people end up just having to
deal with it and that's you know it's
not
um very mentally
healthy to tell someone just deal with
it right
because it does a few things it makes
them feel like one they're not dealing
with
it they're not going through it and two
um you know they're doing something
wrong now it's almost like gaslighting
them
right telling them that uh it's almost
acting like it's normal
and they have to go through it rather
than you know really confronting
confronting the issue at hand
and i think this is something we really
struggle with as a society even like the
muslim community nowadays because
we live in this society the topic of
mental health and
broken families and not having father
figures and not having stable
foundations and not having good morality
and all these things you know
um they're all a byproduct of living in
this broken society
um and it's it's really unfortunate
because society the community just a
bunch of individual people
right but what the hell do you have of
the society when all the individuals are
broken
how's the society as a whole gonna be
stable right and that and that's
something you know
we're struggling with fundamentally and
that's something we need to work on
fundamentally um
you get it man yeah i'm going i think
something everyone needs to take from
this
is i mean there's a lot you can take
from this but um
one of the the more beneficial things
the self-reflective things is that
you always have to put yourself in a
position to better yourself you know
when you can sometimes we feel like we
can't but
um i'll talk about that later you have
to put yourself in a position
where you can benefit yourself and
you're working towards that
and then once you get to that leadership
position you can start leading other
people
to get to that position and then teach
them to lead other people to get that
position
um something you know uh one of them i3
uh really pushes for being a leader that
can create leaders
is fundamentally important for us
nowadays
[Music]
well you got something to say because i
think this is perfect to lead into our
next topic
yeah i mean if we if we're
talking about how to actually rip the
band-aid off
and like deal with everything that's
going on
then it's you gotta get real
comfortable with being alone
and the beautiful things were never
really alone because
allah is always with us but
you have to be comfortable being alone
by yourself
because by yourself when you're not
distracting yourself with something
whether it be some form of entertainment
or something else or whether you be with
friends or family or something
you're by yourself all your demons start
coming out
all that stuff that you've been trying
to lock away in your head
starts coming up to the surface and
that's a
bro a lot of times people will
experience that and
they'll get so anxious although just
they can't handle it they'll immediately
grab their phone or they'll immediately
put a song on
they immediately just do something else
distract themselves
when it's like my guy my girl
that is what you need to go through all
those demons coming up
subhanallah like is isn't it beautiful
how the body knows how to purge and how
the body knows how to heal itself
like a lot has made us so perfectly
where it's like
we just need to disconnect from
everything
be by yourself or more importantly be
with the creator just be
don't don't be doing anything don't
distract yourself and it's like all
these bad things will start coming up
and then all you have to do is literally
go through them like allow yourself
to go through them no matter how hard it
is because bro
even if it hurts even if you start
crying
even if you feel all this pain inside
like it's
temporary it is temporary and you get
past it and i wish i would have known
that
from the rip because if if i did i
probably would have gotten over
everything
within a few months now this is very
optimistic of me but
i'm being honest because it was this
process of like
starting to get to this state dealing
with a little bit and then coming out of
it because i couldn't handle the rest
that was coming up
and while there's nothing wrong with
that it's like me constantly doing that
resulted in healing that could have took
one to two months taking like five to
six
years you see what i'm saying so it's
really just a matter
of being alone being with yourself
without any distractions
letting all the bad stuff come and then
just
going through it i mean literally
there's a saying and it says
the only way out is through and it
couldn't be more true honestly
yo bro that goes hard how many people
are watching this right now
i'm talking to all of you guys watching
this right now that
you just go into a room and you need
something ah you need some sound on you
need something on netflix on you need
something to just literally distract you
from what allah is trying to tell you
and what your body is trying to get out
and what these negative you know these
these unresolved childhood conflicts
that are so
important and they're trying to get
resolved and you just keep pushing them
away and repressing them away
because it's just so hard to just sit
down with yourself for five minutes bro
and it's not this is not me telling you
as an attack because this is a reminder
to myself first and foremost
and these two brothers can testify to
that too but
at the end of the day there's a lot of
things in this dunya in this life
that if you do them short term
it'll give you peace like picking up
that phone
putting on that song doing whatever
distracting short term they will give
you comfort but long term
they will give you this ease or
discomfort and there's a lot of
other things conversely which if you do
them short term they will be very
difficult
for this example it will be not picking
up that phone not putting something on
sitting down in the dark five minutes a
with yourself and just reflecting
all right it's not the body doesn't want
that right so these things short term
they're this they bring discomfort right
they're uncomfortable but long term
they're very comfortable it'll give you
you know peace and ease in the long run
but we don't notice that because we as
human beings
were very you know we're hardwired um
you know by nature
the way we were designed we're hardwired
to only focus on the now
because we're always you know fight or
flight survival so you know we're not
hard-wired to think about
long-term things long-term you know you
know introspection is just a is a modern
you know human type of cognitive trait
that we have
it wasn't it's not it has no survival
mechanism in the wild
right yeah there's a little bit to
forging all that but we can get to that
some other time
short term is all that matters instant
gratification all that matters
if you have someone in the wild um and
and you give them a lot of food bro
they're not going to think about okay
should i save some for tomorrow should i
you know divide it into seven days no
they're gonna eat the whole thing right
now because they don't know the next
time they're gonna get fed
they're only thinking what their with
their instincts right and we
sometimes get like that bro when we get
too emotional which
again and then being emotional makes us
more instinctual
you get what i mean so it just takes us
away from being rational
so my invitation to you as brothers and
sisters is do
what makes you feel uncomfortable and do
more of those things
it might be difficult right i'm not
saying now you know do
some commit some crime because the
thought of committing that crime makes
you uncomfortable what i am saying is
you already know what it is that you're
supposed to be doing if you just get out
of your own way and close your eyes
so just do it right now yeah if you play
call of duty mobile with a controller
you should probably play
without the controller yeah bro
that's that's how that goes hard too bro
but if if we're done with that
if we're done with uh throwing shade
let's say we move to
our next topic
now what time is it something well we
got we got a few minutes bro don't wait
just over four now the main thing that i
want to get at this i'll say it in one
word
and i'll let you guys say whatever comes
to mind right
now the word is judgment right
and i'll throw in a little a little
sense right there
the problem is we as today
we try to act and play the role of god
for allah we think we're in this
position where we constantly have to
judge others and we constantly have to
judge ourselves and we constantly have
to
you know always see or who's doing this
who's not on point who's doing this
it's like yeah it's it's a role to make
sure everyone's straight
at the end of the day along with us but
allah allah is the one that judges bro
why are we out here
always you know being in a position
where we judge and only looking at
people's flaws trying to pick them apart
tear them down
but i'll let you guys uh give me a two
cents for that
let you go first romney since you were
one in chess last night
i'll give you the honor all right
jessica i appreciate it
uh so the specific question you asked at
the end was
why right i didn't ask any question bro
oh okay i thought you asked why um i
just want to know i just want to know
you like
yeah relate to me bro tell me tell me
i'm wrong tell me i'm right
because i think this is a big issue that
in the past i would have yeah and i had
to consciously like
overcome that because we're conditioned
by society just always judge people bro
yeah yeah that is true um
i mean too much judgment um or judgment
and in favor of one way versus the other
is is always a problem right for example
if you're judging yourself too
positively and you're only looking at
you know oh i did this and i'm amazing
right that's that's the problem because
you are you neglect whatever weaknesses
you have
um and you can't work on yourself and
then and you fall into not knowing you
have a problem right but if you're
judging yourself negatively then it's
like you're not focusing on
you know your strengths and you can't
really organize yourself to tear
yourself towards those strengths
um and and judging yourself actively
constantly on your weaknesses
is not actually a good um a good
reflective trait
right it's actually a pessimistic trait
it's it's kind of just hating on
yourself at that point
like angel said it gets to the point
where you're kind of abusing yourself
now judging other people this is a
different thing this this
judging other people comes from many
different um
uh many different places and one first
and foremost we live in a very um
marketed society right especially women
right they're they're
essentially marketed nowadays that they
should look away act away talk away
and um so on and so forth so when you
live in this the society where
everything is to be purchased and you
are to look a certain way and act a
certain way um
the entire this is summarized with the
entire ideology of political correctness
right or even societal correctness that
if you're not acting or thinking in a
certain way
you are a judge for not being like
everyone else you're alienated by it
and living in the society conditions us
to also fall for these things
but this is something i love about islam
because it gives us
the objective basis it gives us the the
foundation and
actually gives us tools uh in which we
can actually
you know be better society for example
creating excuses
for your brother right what's what's
better than that
uh i believe he said that if you see
alcohol dripping from the beard of your
brother right assume that someone spilt
on him
right don't assume that he was drinking
and if you if you if you really
implement that in your life and anywhere
you are um
yeah it's amazing you get to the point
where it's like you're no longer judging
and people judging other people has such
a negative impact on on
yourself because a lot of the time when
we judge what happens we feel better
about ourselves
because we look at them and we're like
they're not as good right
but in actuality a lot of the time when
you're judging other people i feel like
it's a reflection
of yourself something you're not willing
to admit for example a lot of the
brothers when they um they see a woman
without hijab
right there is that that hero that they
they could have they should have that
you know um
you know would be better for her to
cover for the sake of allah that but a
lot of the time it's not coming from
that place and it shows with how they
deal with it
uh in this judge judgmental and negative
fashion
and i find a lot of the time it's
because they couldn't
look away from her and they find that
they themselves
fell into a sin and they want to blame
her for that
rather than accepting that it's their
own you know fault as well
um and that's you know that's not an
external problem that's an internal
problem that they're facing
so a lot of the time judging other
people is just a cop-out for our own
issues
and if you're not actively reflecting on
yourself and being empathetic with other
people
um you're no better than the next guy
and that's a big issue
because you should um actually jordan
peter said uh i think in his 12 rules
for life in his book he wrote um
don't compare yourself to someone else
compare yourself to who you were
yesterday right or don't try and be
better than other people
just be better than who you were
yesterday and i think that that is
fundamentally important
uh as well that's my my tuition sure
very different yo real quick let me just
slide in something before you go on
yeah i'm talking to yuano that he's
right bro about the thing with women
women are
marketed towards today and society knows
that because women at the end of the day
um they're hardwired for this trait
called group think
right in evolutionary biology so
groupthink is basically like if everyone
thinks one way
i'ma think that way too right that's
also why they're also vulnerable to
pre-selection theory
but that's not relevant my point is when
you have a woman today
the average woman if every girl is doing
some tick-tock
challenge they're going to want to do
that tick-tock challenge if every woman
is wearing false eyelashes they're going
to want to wear false eyelashes they
don't even know why they're doing it but
it's like
to be outcasted from that society from
that social order from that group
it's it's too uncomfortable bro if every
woman has this they're going to want to
do that too
so where i'm going with this is society
knows that and
you know consumerism and and you know
all these big major corporations they
know that right
what is it like 70 or 80 of uh every
dollar spent today
is from women right so they know that so
at the end of the day he's right and
women also will want to
you know fall prey to that what i would
admire though i know a lot of women
today
and they've kind of you know drifted off
from that and they stop judging other
people they stop backbiting other women
they stop talking
you know smack about people i know a lot
of women all they do is gossip right so
if you're the former type of woman that
i said that you're trying to actively
and men too
you're just becoming a better version of
yourself just like rami said
stop judging people man the benefits
it's gonna have on your life
is astronomical strikes
it's facts bro
i believe that judgment
is a defense mechanism
it's a way that our mind
uh utilizes something in order to
survive
because um yes it's cool i'll try to be
quick no no
okay think about if you out in the wild
you need to judge certain situations
you see a snake pattern
in the grass you better judge that
accordingly
because your next step may be your last
and you might step
right where that snake is and get bitten
and
i'm sorry buddy but there's nothing
around you that's gonna save you
all right so it's like the judgment is
necessary
in order for us to survive but look at
how we live
look at how we live now and just try to
imagine
what we lived like before we had all
these technological advancements
before we had all these things available
to us
we we were living basically in a
dopamine detox state
we were living in a very pure and
natural state
and judgment was very necessary
to survive now we live in a time where
you need judgment but you don't need
that much judgment you're over here
talking to someone having a conversation
with your own friend you don't need
judgment
but the reason why your mind is still
judging is because that's
just your mind your mind is a tool
why does your heart beat it's how it
functions your heart has to be
you can't tell your heart to stop
beating if your heart stops beating
you're done
like good night bro good night you are
not gonna be here anymore if your heart
starts beating
so it's like you can't tell your mind to
stop doing
what it's naturally gonna do you just
have to understand
okay this is what the mind does
and if i'm stuck in my mind if i'm stuck
in my head
with the mind just going off thinking
this this and that
well then i'm at the mercy of whatever
is going on in my mind if my mind is
judging something that i'm at the mercy
of that because then i'm
i'm literally going to be a slave to
whatever my mind is judging my mind is
saying ah this person
is uh this person is a cuck
like i'm gonna start treating them like
a cook i'm not even gonna give them the
respect they deserve
i'm not gonna it's like what romney said
whereas like if you see your brother
with alcohol dripping off his face
like bro i i would judge the dude i'm
like this guy just
had some drink bro this guy ain't
serious he's not muslim
but it's like bro you don't need that if
you're stepping outside of your mind
if you know how to use your mind as a
tool that it is
and you're able to be present more
present in these situations
then you have the ability to be
compassion and
to give people the benefit of doubt and
to
actually experience life without
judgment but it's like it takes a lot of
work man
it doesn't even matter
at the end of the day most of the time
that you see someone
that you're talking about with with
alcohol dripping down their face and you
judge them
it's because you you fell asleep with
the bottle beside you and
you're trying to get mad at yourself but
you don't have the guts to get mad at
yourself so now you're going to get mad
at another person
yeah what is up with that bro i get it
man life is hard man
every day is jihad like every day is a
struggle for the cause of allah
every day is is an effort every day is
its own battle
but it's not going to end if if you just
keep you know being blind
now if you want to go deeper with this
content i'll tell you what to do all
right if you want to go hella deep like
you want to you know
fully zone into this you like what we're
talking about become a patreon all right
but if you're just trying to get a
little deep
i'm just trying to you know get your
foot in the water just get a little wet
i would say then watch on how's video on
i believe it's how to harness
your masculine energy or how to increase
masculine energy he goes a little deeper
talking about uh you know meditation
and just calming down and letting your
mind catch up because
the mind loves to think bro it loves
this
this monkey brain you know bruce lee
talked about it decades ago
where we just love chattering and this
thing's always on right it's not
easy to just calm down and just be in
that science but
it's uncomfortable and you grow from
that
i mean what is the time
it's 4 18. 14 man i see uh i see we
wrapped this up
all right all right yeah all right y'all
so if you made it this far
go ahead and hashtag onlyfans
and um we hope the video helps
well the video helps someone if if
you're going through something
you know you don't have to legitimately
going through abuse like i did
um abuse can show up in many ways shape
and forms
um it could be yourself it could be
someone else
um just we hope it helps
yeah so sorry i want to slip in very
quickly something i wanted to say
earlier but i forgot um
if your situation is severe right like
like like severe depression or severe
you know suicidal thoughts
tendencies you need to seek professional
help right
um it's not enough to watch a video and
and sit down by yourself when you're in
that state
um but you know there's a place for that
where you can do that safely so seek
professional help i just want to get
that out there so nobody gets the wrong
idea
yeah you know what bro that is not legal
advice
nor medical advice yeah yeah you
wouldn't be saying that if you had the
health you know would you
now well what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
comment right down below
in the description box i'm gonna put in
some links for various different sources
that you guys
guys and girls can check out right i'm
going to try to find one for like let's
say
you're you're a victim of abuse at home
and you don't really you can't really
escape or you can't really
talk to someone about it you don't want
to be seen we can keep it anonymous i'll
put another link for mental health if
you want to
you know find a helpline something like
that but at the end of the day guys
life is short you only got one life
i'm not gonna say stop suffering sound
like you know
holier than that but at the end of the
day some of the worst people i know that
are suffering the hardest are the people
that are choosing to suffer
and they know they're suffering right if
you don't know you're something cool but
you know you got a problem and you're
still choosing to suffer
we're not talking about like absolute
trash people that are now making other
people suffer
you know you're suffering bro and and
the only one you're supposed to be
you know worrying about their approval
is allah
come on yeah [ __ ]
100 percent um
all right so i'ma let romney close it
off but again
thank you guys for watching this video
and again if you made it this far
hashtag only fans
romney take it away bro
i hope this episode was um very helpful
to you guys it was a very heavy topic
may allah bless you all may allah bless
brother angel for sharing what he shared
and uh grant him the best of this life
and the next as well as everybody
watching
and the brother to my left here
masha'allah
with that being said
[Music]
oh that's like the untold story of
feminism like the idea that oh feminism
was just
women who wanted to vote like that's
that's like a cartoon caricature like
that's not really
like the true full story like the
original feminists
were the colonizers these european men
who want to save
you know quote unquote save muslim women
as an excuse to
control and take over and kill muslims
so for a muslim to be a feminist is like
the most ironic thing
and it's the most backwards and
contradictory thing
no two things could be more incompatible
[Music]
hmm